[Music]
time back talk with the king now we had
Deontay Wilder Luis Ortiz - never
thought we'd get here this isn't the
fight anybody wanted would you clamor
for it why because they had a good fight
the first time the good fight the first
time was free now this is pay-per-view I
don't see anything that either one has
done to warrant pay-per-view for this
fight at all was it a good fight the
first time yes it was
do we have drama and high stakes in the
first fight yes we did
but I see this as let's call a spade the
spirit I see this is more of Deontay
Wilder reaching back seeing Luis Ortiz
struggle and nobody giving him a shot
not one champion Joshua
trying to take the easy road and he got
smoked
so again Deontay Wilder reaches back and
gives this guy a super payday and this
inevitably bite Dion Tanner and in the
back side yeah is it possible it's
possible but the mental toughness of
this man is incredible now I got a
chance to see both guys train not in
person through video made a couple of
phone calls to find out exactly what was
going on in each training camp to be
honest with him and what I was told with
Luis Ortiz he's never been in this type
of shape ever ever since he's been here
so that will be cause for concern and
then I saw Deontay Wilder which he's
always training like a beast I saw him
at the weigh-in and
- 19 5 pounds overweight from his last
fight his previous fight with Dominic
Brazil and it was uh how can I say he
wasn't as chiseled as I like to see him
but also he's a grown man
so he's grown in this stature his
biggest attribute well people will say
Oh as big as I do this is right here
known as big as I buta society on t
Wilder so it's hard didn't diminish at
all his confidence didn't diminish at
all he's going in the ring with a man
that he has beaten before so any
trepidation that he had in the first
fight is alleviated now now does that
work in Kemps come you can say Louis
Ortiz probably thought he was the
superior boxing going into the first
fight which he is on paper yes he is
and he has shown that in the first fight
in the first fight I thought he was
decisively beating Deonte was about how
many times have we heard that until
Deonte puts that hand on your head
and straightens you out stood you up
pause so you guys got to understand
right now what we are about to see is
we're about to see two combatants get in
the ring and give it their all they're
fighting for their children are fighting
for their family they're fighting to be
financially secure and that's all we can
hope for right see Louis RT C's des says
if he beats the ante there's a
guaranteed third fight and hopefully he
can probably have something else or
maybe he can move on to fight Josh or
somebody and Deontay Wilder is trying to
close a chapter on the scariest man in
the heavyweight division other than
himself
so Tyson Fury is doing Tyson Fury things
he's dabbling in him wrestling in an MMA
and he's resurrected his dead career
after his drug rehab stint and coming
back from self-indulgence
over indulgent destructive behavior that
cost him his championship so he's
finding a newfound validity in being a
victim but back to the people that
actually hold it together then actually
don't partake that actually give it
their all those are the ones that should
be celebrated those are the ones that
should be on a couple of People magazine
or any magazine or any occupations that
they can get and receive so what they
must do is they must fight each other so
we understand what this is right okay
inside the shoes but on the other foot
Deonte said it best himself it just be
another crackhead story so this fight
tonight how do I see it going man listen
it can go 12 rounds it could go one
round that's every fight you tuned into
the King to get to King's prediction I
give him five
Deontay Wilder in five I think
the first knockdown he quote Luis Ortiz
within the first fight it wasn't clean
it was a it was a it was a it was a
punch that was high on the cheekbone
chin area but it wasn't clean then when
he started hitting him with clean shots
like the uppercut and stuff those shots
actually felled him so I see Deonte
while the victorious in this fight
kaolin five could it be a TKO five years
thought to see him separating Luis Ortiz
from his consciousness that's highly
possible if you can catch him flush if
he can catch him flush I think he cannot
come out
cold Deonte and five this is combat talk
with the king get you guys later
oh by the way since y'all here like
follow and subscribe and hit that join
button down at the bottom so you can
file follow the iron Lords man we got
some stuff cooking up stuff coming polis
see you next fight and we got a Anthony
Joshua vs. the little engine that could
part too
[Music]